ich komme gar nicht mehr mit wurdest du
ausgetauscht gegen der intellektuellen
zwillinge oder was ist hier passiert ich
kann gar nicht mehr voll sofort die
richtige nikolaus beinahe wieder das
buch an zu lesen und sie ist die ganze
zeit die fratze von diesem houellebecq
betreibt diese art von verweigerung cez
tätigte wo er hosen reproduziert
intellektuelle posen
wenn du so willst du was hässliches an
sich haben ich finde über den
literaturbetrieb geht er schon noch sehr
weit er wagt sich schon auf position die
man sonst nicht zugänglich würde mit
einem auto der jetzt nicht von
vornherein als abseitig betrachtet es
geht um einen mittelalten mann mitte
vierzig vermögen verbitterter der keinen
mehr hoch kriegt der seiner freundin
seiner asiatischen überdrüssig ist und
abhaut sich in einem hotel einquartiert
und dann so ein bisschen auf die
erinnerungs spur geht nach seinen
ehemaligen freundinnen dem einfluss von
antidepressiva
das einzige was nicht vorkommt ist das
wort islam aber sonst ist es so wie von
allen möglichen aspekten die ul wechsel
zur verfügung stehen nimmt man so ein
bisschen was sodann hat man dieses buch
man sieht doch wenn man ein buch gelesen
hat auch so ein bisschen bilanz oder hat
sich das jetzt rein ökonomisch
eigentlich gelohnt für mich hat es sich
nur gelohnt das buch zu lesen damit ich
mit anderen darüber sprechen kann ich
finde interessant dass wir bei keiner
dieser fälle ist die zu extrem
dirigenten kritiken einladen und die
frage ist warum ist das so
du hast sich eine antwort parat ich
kenne jetzt hat haben eine antwort
finden in rheine ist eigentlich völlig
entbehrlich könnte dieses gespräch mit
mir selbst finde ich versuche auch
amanda ist an diesen tagen wiederholen
aber irgendwie werde ich nicolas steiner
nicht wirklich los ist also sag mal
warum sind die uns spontan so
unterschiedliche houellebecq geht man
kann ja nichts kritisieren ohne auch ein
statement über sich selbst als kritiker
oder kritikerin abzugeben und bei
houellebecq ist es nun so dass das
leider in den vordergrund tritt es gebe
auch noch eine andere begründung und die
wäre dass man alles was man für wolbeck
ins feld führen kann auch gegen ihn
verwenden
er sprach dabei die sprache natürlich
bei houellebecq auch sehr
unterschiedlich es gibt sehr sehr
gelungen setzte und es gibt viele sätze
die daneben sind aber das ist ja ein
bisschen das programm ich bin immer ein
bisschen misstrauisch wenn man dann als
kritiker oder kritikerin die ganze
arbeit leistet und im auto immer absicht
unterstellt und können unterstellt meine
letztendlich muss er davon ausgehen dass
der autor wenn ein buch schreibt sich
daraus dabei überlegt was wäre die
theorie dass das ganze buch quasi selbst
wie eine starke beruhigungspille
wirklich ein bisschen ein
[Musik]